[Music]
the former coach at Arkansas now working
for CBS sports college football analyst
Houston Nutt by the way looking great
Houston thanks for joining us good to be
here
all right McLovin your question that
involves the SEC and might bother
Houston Nutt no I want to hear coach
make his case here which would you
rather go to in person to see the
Olympics in Rio or the SEC game of your
choice this fall well I'd say I've seen
a lot of SEC games so I'll go to Rio
yeah I've been there one time before
with Eddie Sutton's group and I had the
privilege to be there with the triplets
sit on the bench but I got to play a
little bit and that's a beautiful place
beautiful place wait you played football
and real basketball oh oh
okay both oh you did yeah no I didn't
know that oh so that's why you wanted to
shoot hoops with yeah every time I turn
to noon you're shootin hoops in between
them yeah that was my go I want to shoot
hoops with oh I am the Nick Saban of
shooting hoops just to let you know this
this story greater is it's a story about
a walk-on his name is Brandon bull's
Worth and he had a dream of playing in
the SEC so he goes to the University of
Arkansas and he's a walk-on he had
glasses those big black yeah Clark Kent
glasses the movie by the way opens this
Friday and if your coach bring your team
if you're a parent you want to bring
your kids and their friends to learn
more go to greater the movie.com you can
watch the trailer as well how did this
movie get made how did somebody realize
that this guy was worthy of doing a
movie on you know Brandon was talked
about a lot of it you know that the
tragic death he when he passed was so
sad now that's right after he got
drafted by the cold right after 10 days
after Dan right after right after he
just had a good you know how they bring
the rookies in after the draft yeah they
loved him he was really I think
coach Mudd said he's the only rookie
they gave the playbook to because they
knew they really thought this guy would
start they thought Brandon would start
as a rookie either guard or tackle so
walk-on who now is gonna start the NFL
exactly and I thought he'd be there a
long long time and I believe he would be
he he had such character you know it's
almost too good to be true when I first
met this young man kind of shy big
six-foot for 315 pounds weighted after a
meeting kind of hung around said coach
can I visit with you minute yeah sure
Bren would you please don't ever use the
word rebuild we we haven't had much
success but my teammates Russ Brown and
grant Garrity named a few guys Anthony
Lucas Clint sterner we paid a price we
were ready to win and we want to win
what do anything you want us to do but
they've been four and seven and four and
seven
and so really sent a message to me like
hey look are you getting the freshmen
ready for the for the new wave because
this is only have three months of
football left at Arkansas and so we sent
a real message so anyway long story
short an answer question I just think
there was so much talk about this guy's
a walk-on who earned a scholarship
all-american and you know I think with
his brother Marty and a few other people
who said hey this would be a great great
movie people are gonna cry at this
aren't they I think so thanks though how
did you find out he had died in a car
accident I got a call and this this
tells you a lot about Brandon - he told
me that the day before says coach
tonight it's Wednesday so I'll be
driving home we're passing out our
championship rings our SEC Western
championship rings and I says it's
Wednesday so I'm gonna take my mother to
church like I always do on Wednesday
night so I'm gonna miss them the handing
of the the meeting of the rings okay all
right come get driving homes driving
home from Fayetteville to Harrison today
and how far is that it's about sixty
sixty to three miles but it's a winding
road yeah so he's driving home take his
mom to church next day misses the ring
ceremony right and then dies in the car
exactly so I get a phone call and it's
just you just in shock
believe it movie comes out on Friday
it's called greater and Astoria's
Brandon bull's worth a walk-on now we
consider the greatest walk-on that's a
documentary it's not a movie it's Rudy
oh great I mean that's not a movie
that's a documentary it's a true story I
love it yeah do you have a favorite
football movie
I love Rudy I love Rudy you cry at Rudy
have you cried how would you have
handled if everybody's bringing their
jerseys in and putting it on your butt
would you cut Rudy did you ever have a
yeah yeah no what what what purpose to
those guys you know what they serve it's
it's it's so contagious in the locker
room that this guy you know the the
starters are looking down at this five
foot six guy and they know that he'll
never probably step out in the field but
he said every practice holding that
dummy hand in a Gatorade dude he's a
teammate a thorough 100% teammate you
know he he's a cheerleader for you
always there what's tougher coaching in
the SEC are recruiting in the SEC
recruiting is 24/7 365 days it's it's
it's always the toughest and it always
comes to have those last five or six
that is for sure
the hardest job who really broke your
heart what player broke my heart I got
to go to Rocky Top in Knoxville in 1998
we are rolling and the ball slips out of
Clint's stoners hand I really feel like
if we win that ball game we're going all
the way and we fumble that ball and we
gift-wrapped for Phil former a national
title they score the very next part of
the two plays later they score we had
that game won we're trying to run out
the clock
did did Fullmer ever thank you I always
remind you
hey you need to thank me maybe your best
give me your best recruiting story Oh
what do you want to name names or not
yeah won't name names well the best
recruiting stories is when the
assistants have them set up you have
visits 1 o'clock 3 o'clock you know so
you fly in here and you're going from
living room deliver what one o'clock we
get there and it's mama has a spread I
mean I mean it's it's it's chicken it's
mashed potatoes and gravy it's homemade
biscuits you're eating and of course you
never turn down seconds so at 3 o'clock
it's late again and it's homemade apple
pie so I mean even seconds again and
it's 6:30 day and here's another one
it's and I'm looking I looked at crisp
on one of my sisters
don't tell me we got another we got
another dinner tonight and so that that
was tough to feel so bloated and still
be hungry pretend to be hungry we first
met at Oklahoma State this had to be
1988 87 87 88 and you're there Barry
Sanders was there Pat Jones was the head
coach and I just remember I love the
Barry Switzer line Oklahoma head coach
says whatever you do to he's saying to
his own team do not hurt Thurman Thomas
because we don't want Barry Sanders to
get into the game was buried that I mean
we we saw it but you were their best
football player you ever saw well
Thurman Thomas was good to now favor so
he was both these guys were phenomenal
practice players they loved football and
so but Barry I've never seen a guy that
could get into a full-speed
step on the first step did you recruit
him no no really we kind of looked into
it a little bit because nobody was
recruiting Barry Sanders very heavily
he's Wichita Kansas yeah 10 sisters or
brother and I think at the end maybe
Kansas State might have offered and so
George wall stead was recruiting him
and we kind of luck into the deal and
then he gets to campus any vertical
jumps about 42 inches and runs a 437 and
why are you coaching now I don't know I
don't know I still got a lot left but
what mid-50s I'm 58 yeah yeah a lot of
young there was about 32 jobs last year
and about 28 of them were given to 40
years and younger so there's a little
bit of a different swing and I probably
made a mistake after I wanted to take
one break after I got let go for the
first time in my life at Ole Miss take
one breather and I had two or three
opportunities and I thought well always
I'll get the next one after next year
and the more you said on that sideline
now it's a different world of search
firms oh yeah these you search first
yeah and so they want that next hot guy
that next hot off its a coordinator and
they'll have to go through a little
learning curve on the job
would you take a job at a smaller school
oh yeah yeah if it's the right one you
know right one right you just missed the
relationships you miss the celebrated
locker room you know I talk to a lot
like Darren McFadden and talk to him a
lot you talk to a lot of former players
they anthing lucas' and you know you got
relationship Dexter McCluster and well
plus you get to August and you're
thinking that's that's the time like the
feeling now this time of the year eat
sleep football that's the time you can
use if you want to yell at my Dennis
right now like let's say somebody jumped
offside holy moly get over here and jump
offsides and I want you to act like
you're you're coaching and Polly's done
this three times in a row
coach all right Paulie jumps off side
go Paulie run it probably hit it
Oh like yeah like yeah well they know
they know to go hit that hit that fence
there's about a thousand yard yeah so
that's your punishment would be there's
different there we have you know we have
a little variety a little bright you
know you got a you got another snap cow
that's only advantage we have you know
do you did you was your goal to get your
guys to throw up during camp like
accounts not really not really you know
they work out all summer that's it's
different you know back in the day when
I played it was okay let's get ready s
go home get a job and let's come back
and get ready for the conditioning test
well now it's your round a and these
these street coaches I mean you feed
them and it's a great time to be a
student athlete right now let me if you
get you get all the foods you want and
you're in shape so you don't need that
you don't need to kill them the movie is
greater it's in theaters coming up this
Friday go to a greater than movie.com
you can watch the trailer and it's a
tearjerker there if you're a coach bring
your team for your parent bring your
kids and their friends let me tell you
one one little short story about branded
I think I said kind of it tells you
about this guy he he cared so much and
we were getting ready for a really our
first conference game Alabama and we
didn't have a very good practice
Wednesday our offices in the borough
center are there on the side they have
an indoor 50-yard workout and we here as
we come out about 9:45 10:00 o'clock
Wednesday night didn't have a good
practice we hear she kind of [ __ ] we
hear the turf the turf shoes on turf and
it's dark now we hear somebody move
somebody's at there so we will go out
there and it's in its Brandon I said
Brandon what the world are you doing 10
o'clock at night coach I didn't I didn't
practice good today my steps weren't
right so I'm gonna make sure my powers
and counters and my steps are gonna be
right against Alabama and then that that
was his mindset he cared so much he
loved his teammates he would do anything
and he had these words he'd always say
in the huddle you can hear from the
sidelines sometimes was third and one or
fourth and inches how bad do you want it
how bad do you want and just would
resonate in the huddle and with the
teammates and just an unselfish guy just
a winner and gotta go see this movie the
movie is greater and it's in theaters
Friday this segment brought to you by
our Coaches Corner brought to you by
Continental Tire you'll see Continental
Tire at sporting venues across the u.s.
proud supporter of IMS a racing major
league soccer college basketball
Continentals premium products are
available at leading independent tire
dealers car dealers
mess retail companies across North
America for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do great see Houston thank
you
it host of the day to fly in from Rio
and just give I mean guys that's hosted
there how bad do you want the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience